Você sabia que o seu nível de estresse
pode estar escrevendo seu futuro
Alzheimer? Pois é, olha essa descoberta
aqui que acabou de sair. Um estudo
recente avaliou 85 pessoas e mostrou
algo bem preocupante. Quem tem Alzheimer
apresenta níveis de cortisol cerca de
20% mais altos que pessoas saudáveis.
Mas o mais importante não é só o
cortisol estar alto, é a proporção dele
com outro hormônio, o DHEA sulfatado.
Quando essa proporção fica
desequilibrada, o cérebro perde a
capacidade de se proteger contra
inflamação e estresse oxidativo. Veja
bem, o cortisol alto crônico funciona
como uma equipe de limpeza
excessivamente zelosa que acaba
danificando aquilo que deveria proteger.
Ele destrói neurônios, aumenta a
inflamação cerebral e dificulta a
formação de novas memórias. E o pior,
esse desequilíbrio pode aparecer anos
antes de qualquer sintoma de perda de
memória. Ou seja, é um sinal de alerta
precoce que a gente pode detectar e
talvez reverter antes que seja tarde
mais. Então, olha só, se você vive
estressado ou estressada com cortisol
nas alturas, tá na hora de levar isso a
sério. Gerencial estresse não é luxo, é
prevenção cerebral de verdade.